قدد استهداف في مخيم النصيرات في هذه
اللحظات مربع سكني كامل تم استهدافه من
قبل مقاتلات الاحتلال الحربيه في هذه
اللحظات اصابات في هذه اللحظات
تصل م جراء هذا
الاستهداف مربع سكني كامل في مخيم
الصار اسمع اد القرناوي
اه اسمع
عليها
اسمع بنت علاء القرناوي انا
جبتها هذه مصابه مقص سيارات قبل
قليل نحن الان في استهداف مخيم النصيرات
حيث استهدفت المقاتلات الحربيه مربع سكني
كاملب واياكم استهداف
مخيم النصيرات قبل قليل
حيث المقاتلات الحربيه غارت على مربع سكني
كامل حيث استهدفت المقاتلات الحربيه هذا
المربع السكني قبل قليل في مخيم الن سارات
ادى لارتقاء عدد من الشهداء
والمصابين عدد من المواطنين الان يحاولون
انتشال الشهداء من
حركا المناف التي
ضمرت
الرحمه يا
شباب
شهيده طواقم الانقاض والدفاع المدني الان
كان تنجح من انتشال هذه
الشهيده تحت ركام
هذا